An even more elaborate approach to design information was taken by
the Leonardo Project at the MCC in the 1980s. They devoted,
a whole project to determining what is a suitable set of design information, and
some of the, elements that they came up with that go beyond these,
we've talked about already are. Explicit lists of the stakeholders involved.
Okay. Most important is what issues were raised during the course of the design.
And for those issues, what were the possible resolutions and why.
Was a particular choice made? That is, design decisions and the reasons for
making them. Leonardo also stressed various relationships among
the design artifacts. such as versions. In producing this system you
actually maybe producing several versions. Like the professional version and
the free version and so on. And what exactly is in each version,
and what design compromises had to be made in order to accommodate multiple
versions. There is also the questions of revisions. And the time,
the historical progress of the design. What went into each of the,
the revisions along the way. Specific. Descriptions of constraints,
upon the solution and how they're being dealt with. [INAUDIBLE] important, and
what groupings or aggregates of, of design, artifacts implementation,
artifacts configuration files, packaging, components and
so on, did you decide to use, as far as your solution is concerned.